à regarder les nids disant contrôler
parfaitement son accessoire difficile de
croire qu'il effectue un simple stage de
cirque proposé par la mairie de plaisir
pendant les vacances
ce matin-là 12 enfants s'entraînent à
manier cerceau foulards et autres
techniques du cirque les échasses il
savait pas ce que c'était que des
échasses là ils savent marcher avec les
échasses la boule c'est la même chose en
fait il connaissait rien des ateliers et
on voit quand même une progression ils
arrivent à marcher sur le fil en
jonglerie on voit il arrive à manipuler
bon même si c'est que deux foulards ou
trois c'est déjà une bonne progression
par rapport au niveau zéro qu'ils
étaient quoi mise en place en 2004 à
plaisir ses vacances sportives
permettent aux enfants de 4 à saison de
découvrir des activités originales en
pleine période de repos du sport pendant
les vacances le contrat séduit les
enfants
au début je ne savais pas ensuite quand
on a expliqué j'étais plutôt partante
parce que je savais qu'on allait faire
autre chose comme les échasses que
j'avais pas encore faire et que j'ai
appris à faire ma mère elle a toujours
voulu m'inscrire à un truc des cires
parce que trouve que je prends le cros
que je suis là parce que quand je suis
chez moi je fais des l'équilibré
district comme ça pour les apprentis du
cirque le stage se termine vendredi avec
un spectacle devant tous les parents les
vacances sportives elles se poursuivront
jusqu'au 3 novembre